SHARAD JONES: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
Today, we're going to get on
to cloud storage officially.
So we've kind of
dabbled in this a bit.
We've talked about EBS volumes
a bit, we've talked about S3
a little bit, but it's been
in kind of a hand-wavy way.
So today, we're going to
really actually deep dive, kind
of formally discuss what goes
into kind of cloud storage
solutions and so
just so you have
the background and the
knowledge necessary to do it.
And we'll try to go through
some examples as well
and potentially even give a
demo if we have some time.
But either way, I
just want to give you
a quick, quick overview of
what cloud storage looks like.
So to begin, let's go full
screen on our slides here,
slide myself out the
way, and perfect.
So first off, we've talked about
now the kind of different types
of storage available in AWS.
So we have kind of our instant--
ephemeral storage.
Actually, I don't know if we
actually talked about that yet.
So let's just take a
second on what that is.
So there exists
some bit of storage
that is associated with your
instance, with the actual--
or with your-- with
your EC2 instance.
When you stand it
up, you'll have
some sort of-- or you'll have
some sort of built in storage
capacity defined by the instance
type and all that good stuff.
But the important
thing to note here
is that storage is
ephemeral, right?
It's temporary.
Once you shut down your
instance or once you
terminate your instance, you'll
lose all that information.
And so that's why we
use the Elastic Block
Store, right, the EBS.
That's persistent.
That's mountable.
So when I stand on my
instance, I can mount an EBS--
an EBS-- an EBS storage
solution to my EC2 instance.
But if I terminate my
instance, I don't necessarily
have to terminate my EBS.
So that's something
to keep in mind there
and just to be aware of.
Then there's Elastic
File Store, which we
said is kind of a shared drive.
So it's EBS, but shared
across a bunch of people.
And then there's
S3, which is kind
of the persistent but
object-based storage.
And we'll talk about
this concept of block
versus object-based storage.
But that's going to be
available through a URL and it
can be accessed from anywhere--
well, anywhere that you allow.
You can obviously
restrict solutions there
or restrict access.
And then finally,
there's Glacier--
if I duck out of the way--
Amazon S3 Glacier.
And like we said, that's
referred to as Glacier
because it's cold
storage, right?
That's stuff that's
not access frequently.
That's backups.
That's redundant copies.
That's just something
that's sitting
there, lower cost, but not
as fast, so those trade-offs.
So starting on EBS, I want
to officially say or discuss
what the difference between
block and object store is.
You can think about it
like these squares here.
Imagine these squares are some
file, a text file, let's say.
And let's say you want to change
one character in it, right?
It's a text file that's maybe,
you know, a bunch of usernames.
And you want to change one of
the usernames by one letter.
Well, with block storage,
like we have with EBS,
that's-- you physically
change that one letter
and that's the only thing that
changes in the file, right?
It's exactly like if you
were manipulating a file
on your local computer, right?
You could open up a text file,
make a change and save it,
and it would just continue
going through like that, right?
It's effectively just operating
on that open copy of it.
Object storage with S3,
that's a bit different.
So with object storage,
we're storing everything
as one big unit,
one entire file.
And if I want to change
it, if I want to update it,
I basically need to download it,
change it, and then re-upload
the entire file.
So this is not me operating
directly on the file.
This is me just physically
removing the file completely
and putting it back up there.
This is important to keep in
mind because let's imagine
you have a very, very
large file that you need
to make constant updates to.
You might need to rethink the
way you store it in S3 such
that maybe you do something
where you break it
up into multiple
smaller files that
are easy to manipulate
or identify,
or you do something other--
or something else
that doesn't require
you to do this constant upload
and download and deletion
of an object in S3, right?
Because you do pay
for that sometimes,
or depending on the type of--
or the type of
storage class you're
using, which we'll talk about
those different ones again here
in a little bit.
But that is something
to keep in mind.
So the trade-off there again is,
you know, object storage is--
I wouldn't say better, but it
is cheaper and usually more
scalable.
It's easier to define for
these large scale storage
operations versus block store.
That's for, I'm
operating on my computer.
I need to be making constant
changes back and forth from it,
right?
I'm operating on my hard drive.
Kind of think about
it like if you're
working on your local computer.
And you were-- you had
your just hard drive that's
on your computer, your-- maybe
your removable hard drive
or flash drive
that's plugged in.
That's kind of like
your block store, right?
You're just making
changes on those files.
They sit on your computer.
Object storage is I'm
physically sending
that file off to Google Drive.
And when I want to make
a change to that file--
ignore the fact that
Google Docs exists--
if I want to make a
change to that file,
I make a change on my
computer, and then I
re-upload the file entirely.
I don't just operate
directly on it.
And so that's the difference.
That's the block storage
versus object storage.
And again, pros
and cons to both.
The EBS storage solutions, those
individual storage volumes,
they can be attached to one
instance at a time though.
So remember we said-- and
we'll talk about it again too--
EFS is for if we want to attach
it to multiple instances.
EBS is only your computer.
Again, it's one hard drive.
It's got one plug, one
plug coming out of it.
And so it can only
go into one computer.
And so just be mindful of that.
If there's anything that needs
to be shared across users,
EBS won't really work
for that, or if it
needs to be shared across
multiple users at the same time.
It is going to be
automatically replicated
within its availability zone.
So it's going to have some
redundant storage there.
So you will have that kind
of extra layer of security.
You can obviously replicate
across availability zones
or across regions even if you
wanted to, if that's important.
Another nice feature that
we didn't really talk about
is that you can automatically
back them up to S3.
So let's say you work
daily on your EC2 instance
and you want to ensure that
you don't lose the data that's
on your EBS volume.
So what you can do is
you can just set it up
to have this automatic--
every eight hours, right,
every workday, let's say,
it takes a snapshot
of your EBS volume
and just uploads it
to your S3 bucket.
And just every day, it does the
same thing, that same process.
And so that gives you that
kind of confidence of,
again, I got the backup and
the redundancy on the storage,
but I don't have to do this
manual process of backing it up.
So it's just another
feature you can do there.
And so, yeah, we've
talked about plenty
of ways you can use it,
you know, boot volumes.
So I'm booting from
that EBS, which
I can do so I can have all
my files from my boot process
stored on the EBS volume.
Storage for data or for files,
I can host databases on EBS
if they're fast
enough to do that
or you can choose ones that
are fast enough to do that,
enterprise applications,
all kinds of good stuff.
So kind of the breakdown of
the different volume types,
we saw this when we were going
through the EC2 setup process.
We saw that we could choose
these different types of EBS
volumes.
Oh, sorry, it's always
difficult to point on this.
It's mirrored.
We use the general
purpose, right?
So we did that one
before that first column.
And that's the GP2
and GP3 options.
Those are going to
be your standard ones
to go to for most operations.
You can boot from them.
So they are a
functional boot volume.
And again, if I'm confusing
with the word boot,
I physically mean when I boot up
a computer, it's booting from--
or I can choose such that it
boots from that EBS volume.
So that if I have an operating
system or files or whatever,
or some opening or launch
procedure stored on that EBS
volume, that's what happens
when I boot up the computer.
So it can be a boot volume.
It's fast enough for that.
You can use them for virtual
desktops, low latency
applications, dev and
test environments.
So they're kind of
just your go-to.
If you don't have a
preference one way
or another of what
it should be doing
or you don't really know exactly
what you're using it for,
you just kind of need
something for general purpose,
go with that GP category.
The provisioned IOPS--
IOPS stands for, I believe,
input/output operations
per second.
So that is when
you're trying to have
something that has a lot of--
requires sustained
IOPS performance,
right, it's just a
bunch of input/output.
So you're constantly writing
to and from your EBS volume.
The word slipped my mind there.
You're constantly writing
to and from your EBS volume.
This is something you
want to use, right?
These provisioned IOPS are
a good solution for that.
An example of that is really
large database workloads, right?
If you have a massive
database that your customers
or your employees are using
that they're constantly
writing to and from,
provisioned IOPS
is going to be much,
much faster than using
any of these other solutions.
So that's what that's there for.
But, obviously, you do pay
a slight premium for that.
So it's always a
case of considering
your needs at the time and
optimizing the solution there.
Then for hard disk drives,
you can choose those as well.
But note that neither the
hard disk drive solutions
can be used as boot volumes.
It's really due to time, right?
They're slow.
Historically, we have booted
off of hard disk drives.
You might even have a
computer still that boots
off of a hard disk drive.
It's just very slow.
Most modern laptops
and computers
have switched to using a solid
state drive of some sort,
whether it be NVMe two-slot
or something like that.
They try to maximize the--
or use the fastest memory
they can for the boot volume.
And then you can
still have a hard disk
drive as your backup
big data storage.
Because those are cheaper
per gigabyte than solid state
drives at the cost of speed.
And so that's exactly
how they're used, right?
So those throughput optimized
ones are still decently fast.
So you can use them for
streaming workloads.
So if you had, for example,
streaming web data, right,
you had all the clicks
on your website,
and you have a massive website,
you could use it for that.
It's going to be fast
enough, more than likely,
for it-- depends on
your website for sure.
But, again, the real
benefit is they're
much cheaper per gigabyte
than your equivalent
solid state drives.
And so they're great
for those big data
workloads, data warehouses.
When you have a bunch
of logs, right, you
have an app or something
that's hosted in the cloud,
you can use one of
these hard disk drives
to store all of your logs.
So that way, if something
breaks or there's some issue,
you can go back through
them, but you're not
paying a ton of money for
storing all those logs.
And then there's obviously
the cold storage, kind of
similar to how we talked about
with Glacier in that these are
kind of known to not--
or when something's not
going to be
frequently accessed--
and maybe even logs kind
of fall into that bucket.
Maybe you're fairly
confident, it's a mature app.
You probably don't need
to access the logs often,
but you still want to have them.
You can put them
into cold storage.
And, again, sacrifice
is always speed, right?
So it's this trade-off
between speed and cost
at almost every turn.
So that's just a
thing to think about.
So we've talked about the
fact that, first off, you
can snapshot your
EBS volumes, right?
So you can set
that on a schedule
or you can manually do it.
You can recreate your
volume from a snapshot.
So when you go into
create an EBS volume,
you can actually select to
choose a snapshot at that time
that you want to--
or snapshot from
S3 that you want
to use to create
this volume from.
You can copy them, share
them to different regions
for extra bit of reliability.
You can encrypt the data
that is being transferred
between your EC2 instance
and the EBS volume
within a data center as well
too for no additional cost.
So if you need that
extra layer of security
or, again, there's
no additional cost,
if you just want that
extra layer of security,
throw it on there.
And then any transfer
of information
is encrypted such
that if somebody
were to inject themselves in
the middle of that transfer
between your EC2 instance
and your EBS volume,
they would not be
able to decrypt,
or at least should not be able
to decrypt the information that
is making that transfer.
Because, again, we've been kind
of talking about it as like,
OK, this is an EBS instance
directly plugged into your--
or an EBS volume directly
plugged into your EC2 instance.
That's not technically true.
These are servers sitting
in a massive data center.
And so they're not going to be
directly, directly connected
or kind of directly plugged
in, kind of isolated air
gapped from other solutions.
They will go through
some network processing.
And so, therefore,
you can encrypt them
when they're making that
transition from your instance
to your volume.
It's unlikely that there will
be a risk there, but, again--
and you might even
have some things
where that's required, right?
It might be that you work for--
or work on some sensitive data
and legal requirements insist
that if your data is transferred
between any two sources
or any two locations,
they have to be
encrypted in transit.
That is available as
an option in there.
So keep that in mind.
And then finally,
it's really nice.
They are elastic.
So slide myself over here now.
What we mean by elastic is that
you can change them, resize
them, add new volumes
on the fly dynamically
without stopping your instance.
It's, again, exactly like
if I had a flash drive
and I plugged it
into my computer.
And then I say, oh, I
need some more memory.
I'm going to plug-in a
different, bigger flash drive.
Or I'm going to take
this flash drive off
because I'm going to need
it somewhere else, right?
Maybe I'm working on
my instance and I'm
having an EBS volume
attached, but then my coworker
needs access to something
on that EBS volume.
I can detach it and attach it
to their computer too, right?
It can only be attached
to one at a time,
but I can do that on
the fly dynamically
without having to shut down my
instance or anything like that,
so.
OK, so then on to S3.
So Amazon S3, simple
storage service.
So some quick fast
facts on this,
some bullet points,
the reason I kind
go through a lot of these
bullet points is, again,
a lot of these questions,
a lot of these points
are questions on the--
or potential questions on
the certification exam.
So if that's something
you want to explore,
I want to make sure you see
some of these bullet point facts
that they expect you to know.
So as we talked
about, though, S3
is object level
storage as opposed
to block level storage, right?
EBS, elastic block
storage, is block storage.
S3 is object storage.
And so that means, again,
if you make a change,
you're going to need to
re-upload the entire modified
file.
You can't just make
a change on the spot
to that specific
portion of the file.
All S3 objects are
stored in buckets.
So that's-- it's just the
name, the nomenclature they use
for it.
It looks kind of
like a file system.
And let me see real
quick if we have
plans to go through
a tutorial on this.
I think we do.
I might actually, though, just
open up your eyes in a second.
And once we finish this,
I'll open up S3 and show you
how to access a bucket
and what that looks like.
But either way, bucket
names are universal.
So it has to be unique
across the entirety of S3.
So all users that use AWS, there
can be no duplicate bucket names
because S3 buckets
are accessed via URL.
So that URL is going to
be unique to your bucket.
Therefore, it
needs to be unique.
But it's not as bad
as it seems, right?
I mean, you can imagine
there are infinite names
that you could name something.
So you could always just add
one, two, three, four, five,
whatever the number is at the
end until you get to a point
where your bucket
is uniquely named
if you have some common name
that you're using for it.
You basically have
unlimited storage capacity.
I don't like to use
the word unlimited.
They use the word unlimited.
It's obviously
constrained by however big
their server farms are.
But by the time you
upload enough data
or you go through the process of
uploading enough data that they
run out of storage,
you can probably
assume that they would
have upped their storage
capacity to match the demands
of you as a customer, right?
You'd be paying so
much money in storage,
they'd probably just use that
to then build some more storage
or some more data centers.
So for all practical purposes,
it is unlimited data storage.
But a single object is
limited to 5 terabytes.
So, for example, if you have
a snapshot of your EBS volume
or a snapshot of a database,
those are single objects.
A snapshot would
be a single object
if you design it that way.
And so keep in
mind that can only
be up to 5 terabytes
in size, which
is a massive amount of data.
So it's likely not a huge issue.
But you might have
some databases
that could get close to that
number, and so something
to keep in mind.
As with everything
else, designed
with 11 nines of
durability, so set something
like in a billion objects
or in a billion years,
a million objects, something
like that, you may lose one.
So, basically, you're
not going to need
to worry about durability.
You're not going
to lose any files.
Data is stored redundantly
across multiple facilities,
i.e. multiple data centers,
and then multiple devices each
in-- within each data center.
So it's not just that it's on
one machine in that data center,
it's on multiple machines.
And then they replicate that
across multiple data centers
as well too.
So a lot of redundancy, a lot
of security in the storage.
So I wouldn't worry
about it at all.
Object can be
basically any type--
so images, videos, texts, logs,
lists, your favorite file type.
Anything that is a file
that is stored on a computer
can be stored there, right?
Doesn't matter the file ending.
Again, as long as it's less than
5 terabytes for a single object,
it's good to upload there.
And then, yeah,
you're going to access
everything via HTTP or HTTPS.
So it's just going
to be via URL.
And we'll see that
in a little bit here.
And then yeah, you
can use your IAM,
your identity and
access management
controls to limit
who can access which
objects within a bucket or even
the whole bucket together, so.
Then we talked a
little bit about these,
but I want to go
through them one by one
just so you can get a sense
of what they're used for,
why you'd want to use them, and
the formal kind of definition
of them.
So the different tiers of--
or different classes
of S3 storage.
So the standard class, the
one you'll probably use more
than anything else, that's
just the go-to default.
High durability, availability,
low latency, high throughput,
it's kind of the fastest
solution, technically,
amongst S3 options.
And while that does mean
it's the most expensive,
the cost is still really,
really low for that.
I think we talked some
about that already.
And so you can use it in
basically really any application
where you need all
those features, right?
You need that low latency.
You need that high throughput.
So I'll give you
an example, right?
You're designing an Airbnb
website or a website
similar to Airbnb and you
need to display images
for every single rental
dynamically, right?
If you've ever
gone on Airbnb, you
know you can tap on any
location, any rental
and pull up all the images in
probably a fraction of a second,
right?
There's no lag time, really
no noticeable lag time there,
assuming you have a good
internet connection.
And that's done by likely--
I mean, I can't
guarantee exactly how
these companies
store everything--
but it's almost certainly
S3 or an equivalent tool
from another cloud provider.
And so, again, if
you look at the code
on the back end of
those apps, it'll
usually just have some
dynamic request to the URL,
to the bucket where
that image is stored.
And so you can just pull
up those images instantly.
And so I did some again, back
of the envelope calculations.
You know I love that.
And so I found there's roughly
over somewhere-- or at least
at the time I pulled this data--
about 7 million listings, each
with somewhere between 5 to 10,
potentially even more photos.
And assuming those photos
are about 2 megabytes each,
which is a fair assumption, that
puts you at somewhere around 70
to 140 terabytes, actually,
not an absurd amount,
but enough that it would
not be logical to store that
on your own data centers or
manage your own clusters--
or, sorry, your own servers--
to do all that storage,
especially when, again,
we need that low latency.
That's always the
key bit there, right?
So we need those content
delivery networks
to be able to deliver
that-- those images rapidly
to any user across
the world, right?
So just a sense of
the scale that you'd
be dealing with some
of these things.
Then there's
intelligent-tiering.
So intelligent-tiering,
as we said,
is just a service,
basically, you
can have that automatically
moves your data to the most
cost-effective access
tier, really without you
noticing is the goal, right?
So there should be no
performance impact.
There shouldn't be any sort
of operational overhead.
You shouldn't be
like, oh, I have
to now make this
change here or I
have to move this from
this tier to this tier.
It should be automatic
and in the back end.
You pay a fee per object
that you monitor, right?
We saw that.
But that then hopefully
is offset by the lower
cost of storing those objects.
And then so, objects that
haven't moved or haven't
been accessed for
30 consecutive days
are then typically moved to
the infrequent access tier.
And that's kind of how
the process works, right?
It's going to go from
that 30 consecutive days
to infrequent access tier.
And then it could even have
a setting where, you know,
you go for an infrequent access
to Glacier storage, right?
So, example, let's
say you're helping
manage the data of a
credit reporting agency.
And so at any time you could
receive countless requests
for a credit report,
but more often than not,
most people don't do it, right?
Maybe when you're
going to buy a house,
you're all of a sudden
getting your credit pulled.
Or a car is probably an even
more common scenario, right,
where you're going to a bunch
of different dealerships.
And all of a sudden now, you're
getting a lot of credit pulls.
And so the credit reporting
agency needs to all of a sudden
be providing a lot of
information for you.
Or maybe it's
something where it's
like you think about a popular
car buying times, tax season,
tax return season is really
common for car purchases.
And so at that time,
you imagine you're
going to be getting hit a
lot with those requests.
But then in other
times it's usually
going to be long stretches
for an individual
before they need a credit pull.
Because once they've
bought a car,
it's probably on average two
to four years before they
consider buying a new car.
So they might not
need a credit pull.
And so in that sense,
you really want
to not keep all that data stored
in S3 standard where you're
paying top dollar for it.
And so you can use something
like intelligent-tiering
to just say, OK, well, if a
person's credit report hasn't
been accessed, you know,
some aspects of their credit
hasn't been accessed in 30
days, 30 consecutive days,
let's bump it down to
infrequent access tier
and just pay the retrieval cost
if we have to do it, right?
Because, again, they
may ask for it once,
but more often than
not, they won't.
And so now we're paying
a lower storage cost.
And so, again, this
is a really nice tool
because now I don't have
to, as an individual,
write my own logic
on the back end
to do this or manually
do this, right,
if it's small enough scale.
But if it's large-scale like a
credit reporting agency would
be dealing with, you really need
to have some automatic tools.
And they have that built-in.
So it's a great
resource to have.
Then you have the standard
infrequent access tier.
So that's kind of where
it would get bumped
to if you're using that
intelligent-tiering
and you haven't
been accessing it.
And so that standard
infrequent access
is exactly what it sounds like.
It's still S3 standard.
So it's data that
you're expecting
not to be accessed frequently,
but when it's needed,
it needs to be rapidly
provided to the user, right?
So that's the idea here.
It's still S3 standard.
It's just that it
may occasionally--
or it's not typically accessed.
And so what they do is they
lower the per-gigabyte storage
cost and then just charge
you a retrieval fee.
So, again, the idea here being
that, OK, well, that retrieval
fee, I do have to
pay it per object,
but the hope is that
it's offset by the fact
that I'm paying this lower
per-gigabyte storage cost.
And so it's just this
balancing act here.
So same latency and
throughput as S3,
just that extra retrieval cost.
So great for long-term
storage, but also
these backup and disaster
recovery scenarios, right?
If all of a sudden my
servers just crashed,
maybe I just have
local servers that
do some certain
aspects of our business
and we don't want to
push that offsite.
We're fine doing it on premises.
But we want to have a backup in
S3 standard infrequent access,
because if all of a sudden
our servers crash and we lose
a bunch of data, we need to be
able to instantly back that up
for a million reasons, right?
I gave this example
here if you're handling
electronic medical records.
Frequently accessed
by doctors and nurses,
you need to have those
ready to go on the spot.
There can't be some
lag of retrieval
of it's going to be
hours before it's
coming out of Glacier storage.
So it's still going to
be that standard speed.
So you can't sustain prolonged
outages or recovery, period.
But then you can get that
duplicate data set kind of
instantly or at the
same speed as you
would get if you had it stored
in S3 storage is the idea.
And then the extension of that
is the One Zone-Infrequent
Access, which is the
same concept, right?
It still has rapid access.
You expect it to not be
accessed as frequently though,
like infrequent access or
standard infrequent access,
but it's only stored
in a minimum of one--
of one zone, right?
The default for standard is
three availability zones,
but this will just put it
in one availability zone.
So that's kind of coming at
the expense of resilience.
That's what we're saying.
You might lose that data, right?
If for whatever reason
you need that instantly--
and it's only stored in
one zone and that zone
happens to go down
for whatever reason--
you might be in trouble there.
But if that's OK, if that's not
an issue you're worried about,
then you get, again, a lower
cost per gigabyte storage.
So here again, example use
case, you're a cloud engineer
and your data scientists
at the company
use EC2 instances for their
analysis-- something I've
done basically every
company I've been at
is we've had access
to these EC2 instances
in some capacity
for our analysis.
There's a few experimental
data sets we're--
you're working with.
And, again, very common, you
might be building some data set
or you might be playing
around with a new data set.
And so you could recreate
it if you lost it,
but it would save
some time and money.
So, equivalently if you
didn't have to, right?
And so the idea
is then, OK, well,
I can back up their
EBS volumes, which
has these experimental
data sets,
to One Zone-Infrequent Access.
So they have a
backup if necessary.
But in the event that
everything goes down,
right, we lose that zone and
they lose their data locally.
They would have to recreate it.
But it's not the end
of the world, right?
They were just some
experimental data sets.
It wasn't kind of priority--
or a priority issue.
It wasn't proprietary.
So those kind of things,
One Zone-Infrequent Access
can actually be useful for that.
And so, again, you
can kind of see here,
this is the whole idea
is this flexibility
to tailor a solution for
your exact business needs
at every point, right?
So One Zone-Infrequent
Access, infrequent access,
standard, intelligent-tiering,
all of that
is the idea behind this, right?
And then, as we mentioned,
we have Glacier storage.
That's kind of the secure,
durable, low-cost data archiving
solution.
We can store massive
amounts of data.
And then these are going to
be prices that are basically
on par with, if not even cheaper
than on-premises solutions.
So that's really
their pitch here,
is that, hey, even if you just
need a backup, backup, backup,
this is still cheaper or
potentially cheaper and still
scalable or more
scalable than what
you would have if you had just
on-premise servers for backups.
You can upload files
directly to Glacier.
So if you have stuff that
you know is just backup,
you can just push it
straight to Glacier.
Or how the
intelligent-tiering works,
you can have just policies
that shift existing objects
to Glacier over time.
So, again, intelligent-tiering
said if after 30 days--
consecutive days-- you haven't
accessed it, let's bump it
down to infrequent access.
You could then say
even if after 120 days,
it's still not accessed,
push it now to Glacier.
Because it's likely not going
to be accessed anytime soon.
So our example
case here is let's
say you're working for the
corporate office of a restaurant
chain.
You store all transactions
nationwide, which, again,
most of these companies do.
Because you never know what
you need out of this or you
might even need these
for tax purposes.
And so because at
some point, it might
be valuable to check
your historical sales.
But then you realize that these
analysts decide that they're not
really going to use--
that the company aren't going to
use any data prior to COVID-19
for their ongoing
analyses, right?
So they're not needing to
frequently access this at all.
Anything prior to
COVID-19, they're
saying it's just different
than what we have today.
And so let's just push
that to Glacier storage.
We'll still have it, again,
if we need it for auditing
or anything down the line.
But it's not being accessed
by anybody on the daily basis.
So let's not waste the
money storing that here.
Push it to Glacier storage.
That's the idea.
And then there's
the extreme of that
because there's always some
extreme to this, the Deep
Archive, Glacier Deep Archive.
So that's the absolute
lowest-cost storage.
That is just for retention,
digital preservation,
whatever it might be,
stuff that you're not
expecting to access more
than once or twice a year.
And so the key thing here
is that the data should
be restored, or at least that
first byte of transfer you
should see within
about 12 hours.
So when you say, OK,
hey, actually, we
need to have a copy
of this, then you
make that request to
say, hey, can I grab it
from Glacier Deep Archive?
You can expect that
within 12 hours-ish,
that transfer should start.
But, again, that's to note
that 12-hour window could be
important.
So if that 12-hour
window is not acceptable,
you might have to switch
to just basic Glacier.
But this is really good
for companies/organizations
that need some sort
of historical data,
usually for regulatory
requirements, right?
The government
typically requires
some sort of backup
for that reason alone.
And so Glacier Deep Archive
can be exploited for that.
So, again, example use
case, let's say we're
working for the Census Bureau.
You need backups of every survey
that the census has ever done
to meet federal requirements.
And then let's say you
have multiple copies of all
this data spread across
different regions
in S3 standard.
So you can take one
copy of everything,
basically, and just put it
into Glacier Deep Archive.
So you have that
backup if you ever need
it, regulatory requirements.
And then you still have maybe
the main copies or the working
copies in S3
standard for analysts
to use and customers and,
really, any public individual
because we can
all-access census data.
That's still sitting
there on the website
ready to go for a user at
any time in S3 standard.
But you have that
backup in case you ever
lose those copies in
Glacier Deep Archive.
Super low cost, you don't have
to worry about that at all.
And so this is roughly what
a bucket URL looks like.
And, again, like I said, we'll
pull up S3 here in a second
so you can look at it.
But the idea is that
you create a bucket in--
pick your favorite AWS region,
probably the one closest
to your users.
Upload anything, any objects
you want to that bucket.
And then it's going
to-- the URL where
you access those files is
going to look something
like this, right?
You can kind of choose
either one of these.
They're both going to go
to the same place, right?
It's going to be something
about the location, S3, dot,
the region name,
amazonaws.com/--
your bucket name.
Or you can throw the bucket
name before this S3 and region
name, amazonaws.com.
So it's just a URL that provides
you access to that bucket.
For pricing-wise, you're only
going to pay for what you use,
right?
So you're going to pay
in gigabytes per month,
transfers out to other regions.
So if you transfer your
data from one region out
to another region, you're
going to pay for that.
You'll also pay for any sort
of PUT, COPY, POST, LIST,
or GET requests, right?
So these are API calls
that you might make to.
That you will pay for
those as well too.
Very small amounts,
so it's not something
you have to worry about usually
on an individual user basis.
But when you scale up
to organization wide,
it's something to keep in mind.
The nice thing is you don't
pay for transfers into S3.
So you can upload
as much as you want.
You'll pay, obviously, for the
gigabyte per gigabyte month
cost, but you won't be paying
for the transfer of that.
You're only paying
for transferring out.
So transferring out
to other regions
or transferring
out of the region,
you'll pay for that though.
But transfers out from
S3 to CloudFront or EC2
instances in the same region as
your bucket, you do not pay for.
So if you have an S3 bucket
stored in the US West 1--
which is the Northern
California one I believe,
the Northern California region--
and you have an EC2 instance
that's also in US West 1,
then you're not going
to pay for transfers
from that bucket to
that EC2 instance
because they're within
the same region.
So it's effectively
like saying, you know,
this is close
enough to our data--
your EC2 instance is
close enough to our S3--
your S3 bucket, so there's no
reason to pay for that transfer,
right?
You're just going right
from one to the other.
So case study, I want you
guys to think about now--
maybe pause the video here--
how could a company like
GoPro utilize S3 storage?
We've given some use
cases, some examples
of ways that S3 storage
could be used for some,
or how each different
class of storage
can be used for
different companies.
But what if we take
one company, how could
they leverage all of these
different aspects and tools
within S3 storage.
And I'm going to jump
on to my answer to this,
but definitely feel free to
chime in, post a comment,
post in the discussion board
about this, your thoughts.
But my initial thought was,
let's start with corporate data,
right?
We have sales data, user data.
You might have data on
sponsored athletes of GoPro,
right-- what sports they
play, what events they're
partaking in, which cameras and
which equipment we've provided
to them.
And so these are all different
types of corporate data
you might have.
You'll then also have stuff--
so GoPro has a mobile app.
And so you have to host that app
somewhere or all the information
for that app.
You're going to have to store
all the data that users upload
to that app somewhere
as well too,
and equivalent in the website
storage and hosting side, right?
And then you'll even further
have user video storage, right?
And so the one
thing I was saying
is from that user
video storage side is
you could use S3 standard for
recently captured videos, right?
So let's say you just
captured a video.
You set your GoPro to
automatically back up.
Once you gets an
internet connection.
It's probably expected
that you're going
to edit those videos soon.
And so we're going to put
that into S3 standard cause
it's going to be
the fastest access.
Low latency, high throughput,
that's just that "ready to go"
data right there for you.
But let's say that after
about six months-ish,
you have videos
that have just been
kind of sitting in your storage
bucket, right, or in-- really
in your bucket,
but for the users
to just kind of sitting
in the app untouched.
If it's older than six months,
it hasn't been touched,
it's probably that they're
not going to use it.
So you can bump it down.
If you use that
intelligent-tiering,
you can have it bumped
down to infrequent access.
And so that way if the
user maybe after the year
was planning to do a whole
year-end rewind video,
they may want to quickly access
that video from cloud storage.
And so they still have
that same throughput
as you would get
for S3 standard,
but you're paying that lower
per-gigabyte storage cost
because you put it into
that infrequent access tier.
And then, finally, you'll have
something like S3 Glacier Deep
Archive for those videos that--
it just backs up all videos.
You just take every single
video, back it up there.
And then maybe it's
some premium feature
you offer-- you offer
to your customers,
right, permanent backups
of all your videos.
So if you accidentally
delete a video,
it can always be pulled
back from Glacier Deep
Archive in that way.
And so those are just some
thoughts I have on it.
But, again, I'd love
to hear your thoughts.
You know, put that in
the discussion board.
We'll talk about it, bounce
back and forth ideas.
But this is the way
you kind of have
to think about it is when
you're put into the position
where you make these decisions
on how to use S3 storage,
recognize all the
sources of data
you have in your
company, all the needs
of those individual
pieces of data,
and then identify the
best solution to optimize
costs and user
experience, really,
of your storage solution.
And so I want to open
up real quick here.
Let me see if I can pull
up AWS quick enough.
And I'll sign in.
And we're going to walk
through the actual process,
or just what it looks like
when you launch a bucket.
So logging in now, I've got
multi-factor authentication,
which you guys should set
up if you haven't already.
And so, here, let's
slide this up now.
And you should be able
to see this screen that
has our console on it.
And so you can see S3 here
under Recently Visited.
Or you could just come up here,
type S3, and let's select that.
And so then you can
see here there's
actually a couple of buckets
already made in our account.
And if you can't see
these, it's because they're
going to be not made
to open to the public.
So you see here, these
objects can be public,
versus these say "buckets
and objects not public."
So that means nobody
external to the organization
can view it for sure.
And then within
those, you can even
have individual IAM
controls that can limit
what you can and can't see.
And so I'll click into this.
I think I created some
files in here already,
but this is basically
what it looks like.
And so you'll see
here if I go under--
I want to say it's--
might have missed it already.
Let's see under Info Note.
Ah, here.
Let's just click one of
these files for a second.
So you'll see here if
we click this file,
this is the URI, the
indicator for our object.
So this is one way you
may reference these
if you're accessing these
files from the command
line is using the URI.
And then the URL
is provided here.
So you see it's data3600demo
is the bucket name.
Remember, so under buckets,
that was the bucket.
And then you'll have
dot S3, dot US West
2, which is the region that
this was hosted in or stored in.
And then we have
this fileindex.html.
And that's stored there.
You can see size,
when it was modified,
all that good stuff about it.
And you can also actually
do folders within--
or, basically, yeah,
folders within buckets.
They look like folders
to us as users.
But on the back end, they're
really just another file path,
right?
So if I create a folder here
and maybe call it, I don't know,
"test folder," I can also first
off here enable encryption if I
want to.
And then I'll do Create Folder.
And you'll see now that
shows up there as a folder.
And then let's say I
upload a file here.
So let's just make
a random text file.
Let's do Text,
Edit, New Document.
And so I'm just going to
create a file here and save it.
And I'll just save it to
my Documents folder as TXT.
So it's in my Documents.
I'll click Save.
Sure, let's use RTF.
Doesn't really matter
what the file type is.
And now I can come here and
choose Upload and do Add Files.
And we're not going to upload
that, but we'll do here.
And we should have--
yep-- our test.rtf file there.
And then let's go
ahead and choose--
oh, it was hidden behind my
monitor here, Upload button.
And you'll see now,
upload is succeeded.
View details below.
That's the destination.
Then I'll click this file.
And you'll see here now
that the URL is still
data3600demo.s3.us-west-2.
But now it does
/testfolder/test.rtf.
And so I can continue doing more
and more nested folders in here.
And they would just be slashes
in that URL or the URI.
So that's the idea.
But yeah, so that's, that's
really all that S3 is.
I'm not going to get into how
to push things to the Glacier
or set up the
intelligent-tiering.
It's not critical.
Those are just simple button
clicks if you ever came to it.
But in this class,
we're only going
to use S3 standard storage.
So let's just focus
on this for now.
So I'll leave you with that.
Play around with this.
Maybe try uploading a file.
Again, you'll have
an assignment here
that allows you to
do it in a little bit
and test make sure you can do
it and then we'll go from there.
So yeah, I hope you
enjoyed the video
and I'll see you next time.